[Musik]
Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Mitri
Serien in allen einen schönen guten
Abend den Sport denkt später mit Rudi
Cerne hallo schönen guten Abend und wir
blicken jetzt gemeinsam auf die Themen
Streit über flüchtlingskosten Länder und
Kommunen wollen deutlich mehr Geld der
Bund zeigt die kalte Schulter
marode Autobahnbrücke gesprengt die
wichtige Nord-Süd-Achse bei Lüdenscheid
bleibt noch Jahre lang unterbrochen
nach der Krönung Großbritannien feiert
mit Straßenfesten es gibt aber auch
Kritik an der Festnahme von
monarchiegegnern
[Musik]
durch Corona und Ukraine Krieg war die
Migrationspolitik aus dem Fokus geraten
jetzt drängt das Thema mit voller Wucht
zurück auf die politische Agenda
Mittwoch genau dazu ein
flüchtlingsgipfel zwischen Bund und
Ländern einige Ministerpräsidenten
machen Druck und fordern mehr Geld der
Bund hatte seine Hilfen schon
aufgestockt und will es jetzt dabei
belassen es bahnen sich also schwierige
Verhandlungen an Patricia Wiedemeier
übervolle Unterkünfte wie im hessischen
Groß-Rohrheim oder in Bensheim
überforderte Länder und Kommunen immer
weiter steigende Flüchtlingszahlen die
Länder schlagen Alarm fühlen sich vom
Bund alleine gelassen fordern
parteiübergreifend mehr Geld vom Bund
wir sind entschieden der Auffassung wir
brauchen ein Admin des System ein System
das die Mitverantwortung des Bundes vor
allen Dingen auch anhand der Zahlen von
Menschen steuert die zu uns kommen es
kann nicht damit getan sein dass über
jahrespauschalleistung ganz unabhängig
von der Zahl der Schutzsuchenden der
Bund meint er könne in dieser Hinsicht
seine Aufgabe erledigt haben wir haben
uns übergreifend über alle Parteigrenzen
schon im November abgesprochen 50 fifty
halten wir für eine faire Lösung sondern
etwa gab es das auch in der
Vergangenheit bei uns in
Nordrhein-Westfalen kann ich sagen der
Bund beteiligt sich an den Kosten von
Land und Kommunen aktuell nicht mal mehr
mit 20 Prozent und deswegen müssen wir
auch über Geld reden
zudem müsse die Zahl der Flüchtlinge
begrenzt werden der Bund müssen mehr tun
für die Grenzsicherung für Fortschritte
sorgen bei Rücknahmeabkommen die
Innenministerin verspricht nicht mehr
Geld will aber für eine gerechtere
Verteilung in Europa kämpfen es geht
darum dass man gleichmäßiger verteilt
beispielsweise der ukrainischen
geflüchteten gibt es Länder wie Polen
die viel mehr belastet sind als wir oder
insbesondere auch beispielsweise als
Mitgliedstaaten wie Frankreich es geht
um gerechtere Verteilung gleichermaßen
und darum kämpfe ich am Mittwoch findet
der flüchtlingsgipfel im Kanzleramt
statt und wie so oft vor solchen Gipfeln
erhöhen beide Seiten den Druck der Bund
gibt bisher bei den finanziellen
Forderungen nicht nach für die Länder
bieten die bisherigen Vorschläge des
Bundes wenig Anlass zu Zuversicht
bundesweit fehlen
378.000 Kita Plätze 291
000 allein für Kinder im Alter von 1 bis
3 so die Antwort des
Bundesfamilienministeriums auf eine
Anfrage der Linken Fraktion seit 10
Jahren haben Kinder ab vollendetem
ersten Lebensjahr eigentlich einen
Rechtsanspruch auf einen Kita Platz
17.000 Tonnen Beton wurden heute
kontrolliert gesprengt die rame der
Talbrücke im Sauerland 1968
fertiggestellt ist seit heute Mittag
Geschichte auf der A45 gehörte sie zur
wichtigen Verkehrsachse zwischen
Frankfurt und Dortmund die letzten
anderthalb Jahre war die Talbrücke
komplett gesperrt und das hieß und heißt
Umleitung durch Lüdenscheid Stau Chaos
stockender Lieferverkehr die Folgen
gravierend dort verfärber und Thaddäus
Parade
es ist punkt 12 Uhr als die 450 m lange
Talbrücke in sich zusammenfällt eine
Brücke am Hang umgeben von Häusern eine
anspruchsvolle Sprengung der Jubel ist
groß
sie ist sauber in das fallbett gefallen
und wir sind sehr dankbar für diese
präzise Arbeit der sprengmeisters in
seines Teams und freuen uns jetzt für
die Region dass dieser Tag auch ein Tag
des Optimismus und der Zuversicht ist
seit anderthalb Jahren quält sich der
Ausweichverkehr nach der Sperrung der
Talbrücke durch Lüdenscheid der Dauer
Lärm eine Nervenprobe für die Anwohner
die gesperrte Brücke isolierte zudem die
Stadt wenn nicht kommen musste Weg nach
der Sprengung jetzt überall
Erleichterung
wir hoffen dass die Brücke so schnell
wie möglich gemacht werden dass die LKWs
geringer werden und sage mal dass die
Brücken dass der Brückenbau schnell
stattfinden wird dass wir das mit
unserer deutschen Bürokratie nicht
wieder so hinkriegen dass es zehn Jahre
dauert statt fünf das wünsche ich mir
für alle in fünf Jahren soll laut
Planung die neue Brücke stehen
Lüdenscheid und die Region leiden
vorerst weiter die Situation
exemplarisch ein Stück weit ist diese
Brücke ja auch Sinnbild geworden für
eine infrastrukturkatastrophe die wir an
in Teilen Deutschlands haben und erleben
4000 Autobahnbrücken müssen derzeit
bundesweit saniert werden ob es mit
einer neuen Brücke hier in fünf Jahren
klappt ein klappt Verkehrsminister auch
von der Bauwirtschaft ab
die Internationale Atomenergiebehörde
waren vor einem ernsten atomaren Unfall
am Atomkraftwerk SAP in der Ukraine die
von Russland angeordnete Evakuierung der
nahegelegenen Stadt in der hoda wo der
Großteil der AKW Mitarbeiter lebt mache
die Situation immer unberechenbarer und
potenziell gefährlich so ja Chef grossi
das Kraftwerk wird seit über einem Jahr
von der russischen Armee kontrolliert
schon wieder gab es einen blutigen
Angriff in den USA in einem
Einkaufszentrum in einem Vorort von
Dallas schoss ein Amokläufer um sich
acht Menschen starben darunter Kinder
sieben weitere Personen wurden verletzt
hunderte versuchten sich in Sicherheit
zu bringen weil zunächst unklar war ob
es sich um einen Einzeltäter handelt ein
Polizist der zufällig vor Ort war er
schoss den Mann die Hintergründe sind
noch unklar
am Tag nach der Krönung von Charles wird
Kritik am Einsatz der Polizei geäußert
die etliche monarchiegegner festnehmen
ließ aber die Freude über das neue
Königspaar überwiegt gestern da ging es
ja streng nach Protokoll zu heute er
locker mit tausenden Straßen und
bürgerfestisten im gesamten Land zeigt
uns
sie feiern weiter die Briten ob in
London oder in swininden sogar zu Wasser
wie hier im Cornwall big Land das große
Mittagessen heißt die Idee die alle
Menschen im Land zusammenbringen soll
auch der Downing Street wo sich
Premierminister regisse sunack gemeinsam
mit der Gattin des US-Präsidenten Jill
beide noch ein wenig im Glanz der
gestrigen krönungsfeier sondern wollte
verfolgt von rund 20 Millionen Briten an
den Bildschirmen war da einmal mehr ein
perfekt organisiertes royales Spektakel
gelungen mit allem Prunk und pompt die
die Monarchie zu bieten hat was aber
nicht bei jedem im Land gut ankommt mit
Festnahmen von Aktivisten hat die
Polizei auf der Basis verschärfte
demonstrationsgesetze auf die Proteste
reagiert daran wird die Kritik
inzwischen immer lauter
die Musik spielt allerdings heute im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes in Winser im
Schatten des Schlosses auch hier eine
Straßenparty sogar mit einem sogenannten
stadtausrufe der noch einmal die Krönung
Charles des dritten annonciert Tradition
ist nun mal Tradition
wir haben das gebraucht überall auf der
Welt haben wir ein paar schwierige Jahre
hinter uns aber wie wir schon beim Thron
Jubiläum der Queen festgestellt haben
heben solche Ereignisse die Stimmung
und die Royals kommen weiter ihre
Pflicht nach sich zu zeigen wie hier der
Prinz und die Prinzessin von Wales heute
Abend an den Winzer das große
krönungskonzert mit internationalen
Stars und morgen bekommen die Briten
einen Tag frei da können Sie sich dann
vom Feiern ein bisschen erholen
so bei uns geht sportlich weiter mit
Rudi und es wird wieder spannend in der
Fußball-Bundesliga der Frauen ja auf
jeden Fall ein Kopf an Kopf rennen kann
man sagen die Fußballerinnen des VfL
Wolfsburg gewannen am 19 Spieltag der
Frauenbundesliga überzeugend mit sieben
zu eins gegen den ersten fC Köln damit
sind sie im Titel Endspurt bis auf einen
Punkt an Spitzenreiter München ran
gerückt
Nationalspielerin Nina Oberdorf sorgt
bis zur Halbzeit schon für klare
Verhältnisse in der 40 Minute wagt sie
einen Schuss aus 25 Meter kraftvoll und
platziert es ist das 3:1 für die
Wolfsburgerinnen die in die
Mittelfeldspielerin noch vor dem
Pausenpfiff das 4:1 folgen lässt gegen
den Tabellen 9 aus Köln Wolfsburg in
allen Belangen besser mit schnellem
druckvollem Angriffsspiel auch Pauline
Bremer gelingen zwei Treffer hier das
6:1 die eingewechselt Alexandra Popp
kann dann im zweiten Versuch ihr
herausragendes Kopfballspiel einsetzen
entstand 7:1 für Wolfsburg drei
Spieltage vor Saisonende jagen die
wölfinin mit nur einem Punkt Rückstand
den FC Bayern
und zu den Männern die Ergebnisse der 2
Liga spiele von heute Heidenheim
Magdeburg 0:0 die Gastgeber im Pech
einmal Latte einmal Pfosten kein Tor
Nürnberg Kaiserslautern 3:3 der
Ausgleich für Kaiserslautern in der
letzten Minute der Nachspielzeit und
Eintracht Braunschweig SV Sandhausen 2:1
die niederländische Polizei hat im
Vorfeld des Spieles Ajax Amsterdam gegen
AZ Alkmaar 154 Gäste Fans festgenommen
sie hatten auf dem Weg ins Stadion
antisemitische Lieder gesungen
die Berlin Recycling Volleys haben sich
gegen Friedrichshafen erneut den
deutschen Meistertitel in der Volleyball
Bundesliga gesichert Erfolgstrainer
Cedric ENA feiert mit seiner vierten
Meisterschaft in 5 Jahren seinen
Abschied
jetzt schlägt 13 der Tenor nach dem 13
Titelgewinn der br-volleys ihrem siebten
nacheinander Berlin begeistern im
vierten Satz macht deutliche Rückstände
weg und sichert sich mit dem Block von
giardo dalika den Sieg
27 zu 25 und damit nach Sätzen 3:1 eine
optimale Finale Serie für Cedric ENA und
seine Männer 130 Siege gegen
Friedrichshafen beide Konkurrenten sind
jetzt deutsche Rekordmeister mit je 13
Triumphen
und noch einen Zwischenstand zum Schluss
Borussia Dortmund führt gegen Wolfsburg
mit 15:03 hoch danke Rudi dann schauen
wir noch zusammen auf die
Wetteraussichten und die gehen so von
Schleswig-Holstein bis nach Sachsen viel
Sonnenschein in der südwest-hälfte
Schauer und Gewitter im Süden mit
Starkregen maximal 16 bis 22 Grad
bis heute journal um 21:45 Uhr mit
Marietta Slomka schönen Dank fürs
Interesse bis morgen und jetzt rüber in
die Hauptstadt zu Chuck unter la energy
und Berlin direkt